hey you did you know that cell has three
fingers
because he does
here's a picture
now I know what you're thinking no he
doesn't right and I get what you're
saying given all this footage behind me
with cell having five fingers and all
that but what you don't know is that
while the anime adaptation gave cell
five fingers presumably for the ease of
animating them cell in fact has three
fingers see look at him look at him go
poor guy barely has enough digits to
shoot a gun not that he would want to so
can barely flip the bird for real though
it is kind of weird to me that the anime
adaptation just completely erases this
Quirk of his design I feel like it
really makes him look alien and unique
but again I get the five finger version
is largely easier to animate so I don't
know which one do you guys prefer